que tiene que hacer ahora la oposición
Cómo cómo debe recomponerse Sí bueno eso
es un dilema que tiene la posición
porque al final de cuentas ha hecho un
ejercicio de competir digamos
simultáneamente en todas estas
elecciones y obviamente no se les ha
dado sino simplemente una sola vez y eso
es decepcionante sobre todo digamos
decepcionante el resultado que se está
viendo el día de hoy Porque es
básicamente 15 puntos hacia abajo frente
a las elecciones anteriores entonces
obviamente habrá autocrítica habrá
autocrítica sobre todo sobre si el
modelo de candidatura sobre todo del
liderazgo de fraina alegre debe
continuar o quién debe revelar relevarlo
en digamos en ese digamos en esa tarea y
obviamente también es como sumar ese
apoyo de aquellos que no votaron por
alegre tanto aquellos que votaron por
paraguayo cubas pero también aquellos
colorados que de pronto pueden ser
disidentes entonces obviamente digamos
Es toda una tarea que tiene en estos
cinco años por delante de la oposición y
obviamente tener en cuenta que la
digamos no es una posición que se
construya el día de la noche a la mañana
no claramente y precisamente dentro de
esta oposición como usted lo mencionaba
había colorados como la propia señora
Núñez que era la fórmula
vicepresidencial de esta concertación
nacional una ex ministra de cartes y por
otro lado al final acabó retirando su
apoyo a la concertación nacional quien
fue el único presidente de Paraguay no
Colorado desde que se restableció la
democracia hablamos del exobispo
Fernando Lugo No que al final acabó en
la desacuerdo con Efraín alegre y a 48
horas de estas elecciones retiró su
apoyo cree que esto ha generado también
alguna desventaja para a la hora de ir a
las urnas o que no ha tenido mucha
relevancia esta ruptura dentro de la
concertación nacional en las últimas
horas efectivamente tiene un impacto muy
importante digamos así como paraguayo
cubas fue digamos básicamente un efecto
devastador para la candidatura alegre
también digamos el digamos el frente o
azul en ese en ese entonces bueno con
con Fernando Lugo también genera alguna
forma un digamos un boquete importante
de electores que se fugan digamos hacia
otras candidaturas y Que obviamente no
permiten que la oposición vaya
totalmente unida es decir la
concertación busco estar unida Pero no
logró digamos aglutinar toda esas
fuerzas y eso lo vemos por ejemplo en el
caso de paraguayo cubas casi que 20% de
la votación está ahí Y ese 20% era
necesario para competirle al candidato
Colorado Y eso lo que hemos visto es que
obviamente la oposición tiene que
replantearse Cómo llamar a esos que
digamos electores que no están
convencidos de la candidatura de la
concertación nacional mediante programas
mediante digamos otras mecanismos para
que ellos se sumen a hacer digamos a
participar dentro de la candidatura
opositora